salut à tous en 2019 la chaîne mais
karzaï en somme avait construit un casse
tête
hier le propriétaire de la chaîne de
créateurs avaient créé un casse tête de
toutes pièces qui m'avait envoyé vous
aviez adoré cette vidéo ça tombe bien
parce que j'avais adoré son casse-tête
et depuis 2010 neuf il a changé le nom
de sa chaîne en mg maker et il vient de
créer un peu je crois la v2 a priori de
ce casse tête apparemment beaucoup plus
dures qu'il m'a mis un petit mot avec où
il explique qu'il a mis 200 à 300 heures
de travail quatre mois de travail et ça
devrait me prendre deux à trois fois
plus de temps alors ça t'a attention
c'est pas si vous n'êtes pas obligés
d'augmenter tour tant la difficulté
parce que à la fin ça devient un truc ou
faut que je prononce un mot magique que
je ne connais pas on va pas se mentir
quatre mois de travail c'est magnifique
et c'est vrai qu'elle ressemble beaucoup
à l'ancienne je crois que l'ancien
alouette faisait la moitié de la taille
un truc comme ça
bref ces partis loïc générique qui je
suis fier mans équipée de 7 go pro pour
port pour voir comment ça va se passer
donc on a une boîte qui à six faces
jusque là c'est normal on se fait une
petite exploration rapide ici on peut
l'enfoncer
là on a des trous là en un petit bout de
métal ici d'autres trous ça ça bouge un
peu mais on ne peut pas de l'enfance et
encore ces blocs et ça ça a pas l'air
d'être un mot bible lui a pas l'air
d'être mobile lui oui qu'est-ce qu'on a
de ce côté ici ça bouge un peu là ça va
là là ça s'enfonce un peu ici d'accord
pas beaucoup de choses qui bougent
ce côté là une grosse grosse plaque
c'est peut-être un truc d'ouverture et
si des gros blocs
je crois que je vais en français à eau
j'appuie là je me suis ok ça fait sortir
un truc là pas du tout il n'y a rien du
tout de l'autre côté juste on pouvait
appuyer sur celui-là est en dessous on a
un trou et c'est d'accord donc là je
vais repasser surtout pourquoi parce que
comme je viens de changer la
configuration de celui là ça a changé de
configuration ici ça vaut beaucoup quand
même de repasser sur tout le reste
pour voir ce que ça donne alors je vais
essayer de le try hard un peu je vais
essayer d'aller un petit peu vie que je
vous avoue pas parce que comme il dit
que ça va résident en prendre deux à
trois fois plus de temps je vais essayer
de ne pas perdre de temps justement est
d'être le plus rapide possible pour
compenser les points où je vais bloqué
dans la compréhension
je vais essayer d'appuyer là et dorée
appuyée par tous pour voir si j'ai des
différences
donc là là là c'est le bouton qui
s'enfonce donc pareil ça c'est un truc
sur les casse-tête qui est pas mal à
faire c'est si vous n'avez pas beaucoup
de possibilités et qu'il ya un truc qui
change la compères la queue de la
configuration vous refaites tout
l'exploration tout en en étant dans la
deuxième phase de configuration pour au
pourvoir en appuyant sur celui qui est
là juste là là moi ça m'a permis
d'appuyer sur l'âge peut pas l'enfoncer
lâche peut l'enfoncer
il n'empêche que si je relâche ça me
relâche les deux en même temps donc
maintenant que j'appuie sur lui je ne
refais encore tout l'exploration ça
risque d'être c'est quand c'est comme ça
par étapes c'est possible qu'ils aulas
je peux
est-ce qui scella j'appuie là et je
crois que ça soit wes a sorti un truc la
vaste appui on sait jamais et alors
attendez pas ce que je vais pas perdre
mon temps je vais surtout pas perdre mon
temps du tout hossa a fait un certain
temps ça a fait bouger un truc de
l'autre côté là ça m'a fait bouger cela
à d'accord ça a débloqué le fait que
j'enlève lui
donc ça apparemment ça pas tellement
d'intérêt ça m'a débloqué ça d'accord ok
donc ça je peux le pousser ici ça a pas
l'air d'avoir trop d'intérêts attends je
vais quand même regarder mais s'il ya
pas un truc des cris ou poids de sune
par contre ça m'a libéré
ces quatre là j'ai l'impression qu'il y
en a encore au bout parce que j'ai un
tout petit bout de dessin ici ok et là
il ya des trous comme ça sur les côtés
des trous on pourrait en france et la
barre donc ça ça va être un système de
code c'est sûr comme celui qui m'avait
fait en 2019 que j'ai trouvé très malin
un peu d'acteurs observions fallait
compter le nombre de traits via un
indice qui avait où on comprenait le
nombre de traits d'ailleurs ça ça doit
être quelque chose pour ce pour
comprendre le code avec un système de
graduation on le voit quand le tourner
ok je récupère un peu sa logique c'est à
dire que on a un très ici après un
deuxième très un troisième trail
quatrième très et on voit que ça descend
en fait de haut en bas comme ça donc ça
ça doit être mon code du premier mon
code du 2e au code du troisième et mon
code du quatrième ok par contre on peut
pas les pousser de l'autre côté alors
que dans le premier casse-tête qui
m'avait fait ça ressorte et aussi de ce
côté là haut est un signe de pyrogravés
ici qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est un indice de quelque chose et on a
3 et 3 ça ressemble à ce symbole là là
que j'ai ici
si la graver des trucs partout s'amuse
serge attend qu'on a ça on va l'enfoncer
partout titre ici ça pousse un peu l'âme
pour l'instant il n'y a rien qui sort
ici je peux pas l'enfoncer du tout ici
ici j'ai un truc qui sort trois traits
j'ai trois traits discontinus qu'ils
sortent ensemble
là j'ai fait tous les hauts de saint
aubin que je me souviens dans l'ordre
dans laquelle je fais les choses
moi je vais mettre comme ça comme ça
vous verrez mais ce que je fais là on a
donc ça c'est ce qui m'a sorti un petit
bout juste là ça ça ne fait rien ça ne
fait rien ça ne fait rien ça ça me fait
rien oh ça c'était mort abaissé le truc
que j'étais en train de lire tu alors je
vous fais voir sur toutes les caméras
comme ça vous le verrez bien si j'appuie
la sam éjecte lui d'accord il ya pas mal
de choses des clips dessus ok c'est un
truc tu en as oui ça ça me sort quelque
chose sur cette phase il y avait que ça
ici se trouve là mais ça doit être juste
pour retenir au départ et là il ya le
trot du dessous que je peux pas attendre
d'accord ok début du game du coup on a
on a ça ici voilà ça on a ça on a ça et
lui voilà qui sortent d'un côté mais pas
de l'autre alors sages' pas si c'est
normal ou pas ici de l'autre côté on
pouvait le repousser au et bien voilà ça
ça ne débloque pas à temps mais là du
coup je les ai complètement libérée des
deux côtés vous fait voir à cette gamme
là ils sont bien sortis ici et si je
fais ça à plat vous avez ils sortent
bien complètement de l'autre côté ils
sont complètement libres cool parce que
je pense qu'on a fini
le le point de départ du casse tête
c'est à dire qu'au final j'ai récupéré
ces deux objets là qui sont pyrogravés
celui ci est clairement fait pour
résoudre le code avec ces choses là j'en
suis persuadé ça c'est peut-être comme
dans le casse-tête de 2019
un indice pour comprendre comment
fonctionne le code
ici on assortit cette peur aux gravures
là là on a ces trois traits à ce que ça
veut dire 3 est ce que ça veut dire que
le test est à trois étapes à ce que ça
veut dire où en morse je sais pas du
tout mais pour l'instant j'ai pas trop
d'intérêt ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire que trois des quatre bâtons je
pense pas parce qu'on avait quand même
les quatre positions ici là vous avez vu
le départ et est allé vite je pense pas
que qu'on puisse dire qu'il soit facile
dans la compréhension
il est même plutôt dur à comprendre
parce que tout ce que j'ai fait c'est
pas de la compréhension d'ailleurs c'est
que de l'exploration et à chaque fois
que j'ai un changement de configuration
je réessaie tout au cas où donc il est
il est logique mais il n'est pas
compréhensible par contre pour le monde
qu'est-ce que ça ça m'indique là j'ai
deux très là j'ai encore deux traits la
g3 très la g3 très plat il faut que
m'intéresse au nombre de traits mais pas
la nage et deux traits et là j'ai 1 2 3
4 5 13 1 2 3 4 5 très 1 point et 1 2 3 4
5 6 la cij fait nombre de traits plus
nombre de points égale nombre de traits
ici donc d'être égal nombre de très
nombreux très égale nombre de très
nombreux traits plus ce point n'est pas
égal à nombre de traits donc ces femmes
nombre de traits et c'est pas le nombre
de points parce qu'en gros je n'ai pas
encore vérifié mais il est certain que
je ne vais pas trouvé à temps mais c'est
le pendre le premier 1 2 3 4 5
je ne vais pas trouver ce truc de 5,13
symbole là ici il va forcément y avoir
sur
ça peut être lui ou lui qu'en fait comme
lui signe un extrême c'est soit celui ci
la soie ce bâton la soie ce bâton là ce
ne sera pas un des centrales de trois
quatre cinq lui à 5 13
ça pourrait être le correspondant à lui
je peux c'est ça à bâle en ligue 2 3 4 5
donc c'est pas le nombre de traits c'est
sûr parce que le d5 très déjà j'en ai au
moins deux ici et sur celui ci j'en ai 0
je crois à 6 g lui quand même simple
trait 2 3 4 5 et j'ai encore un simple
trait donc ça peut pas être que le
nombre de traits parce que j'ai trop de
possibilités donc de très plus points
est-ce quelque chose de grave et l'autre
côté il va vraiment falloir regarder
tous les côtés de la boîte en permanence
parce que c'est grave et aussi de deux
côtés donc là par contre j'ai des points
sur celui-ci et moi sur lui je les
prends aussi j'en ai un la gd prendre là
et j'ai des points là donc j'aime être
du côté points pour le moment loïc je
vais tâtonner pour essayer de comprendre
ainsi je te propose une accélération
ouais j'ai une petite théorie par
rapport à celui de 2010 9 dans le code
je pense que à chaque fois des deux
symboles sont égaux ils veulent dire
pareil
en gros pour moi ce qu'ils essaient de
dire le créateur c'est ça ça vaut ça ça
ça vaut ça ça ça vaut ça ça va ça donc
si tu comprends la logique tu comprends
l'homme donc si je le mets à part au
début je me disais l'a3 trail il ya
trois traits là il ya deux traits il ya
là deux traits et là on voit bien que ça
marchait pas sur lui je me suis dit ok
nombre de traits est-ce qu'un point
voient un trait sur la il est 1 2 3 4 5
6 et la 1 2 3 4 5 6 mais ça ne marche
pas avec ça donc j'ai cherché pour moi
c'est lui en fait un indice principal
si tu arrives à faire une équivalence
entre lui et lui tutu à la réponse à
tout donc j'ai pris toutes les
intersections en fait tous les moments
où le crayon change de direction comme
quand tu fais un point c'est une
direction
donc là je me dis 1 2 3 4 5 à 5 5 fois
où tout change de direction avec le
crayon et là ça fait 1 2 3 4 5
d'ailleurs je peux je prends des
extrémités avec si c'est le cas c'est un
peu tordu mais si je fais ça ici ça
marche pour cinq là ça ferait un deux
trois quatre cinq avec ici et 6 et là ça
ferait 1 2 3 4 5 et 6 avec ici 1 2 3 1 2
3 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 comme ça marche pour
tous je repasse sur lui lui ça fait 1 2
3 4 5
il n'y a pas de quoi donc ici le 5 comme
on sait que ça va être l'une des deux
extrémités puisque c'est la barre est
supérieur c'est une des deux boîtes
d'extrémité là ça fait 1 2 3 4 5 8
fonctionne un deux trois manches par lui
trop ça marche pas un deux trois quatre
cinq lui fonctionne un deux trois quatre
cinq clics fonctionne un deux trois
quatre cinq lui fonctionne là on en a
quatre qui fonctionne sur la barrette ça
veut dire que pour moi ça peut pas être
cette extrémité là sinon il n'y aurait
pas autant de possibilités si je me
réfère à celle ci ça me fait 1 2 3 4 5 6
1 2 3 4 5 avec le point de trois là y en
a trop 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 4 au royaume a trop
là il y en a pas c'est hélas un deux
trois quatre cinq six là y en a trop
donc là le seul qui vaut cinq si ce
rapport là est bon c'est celui ci un
deux trois quatre cinq donc je vais
l'enfoncer jusque là ça veut dire que le
2 donc lui serait le 1
ça ce serait le 2 donc 1 2 3 et la trois
j'en ai pas ici et j'en ai et j'en ai un
la laisse avec 4 donc lui vaut un deux
trois donc lui pas je le laisse en but
et donc ça me mènerait à lui si ce une
deux trois quatre cinq six ans à
paraître logique que ça va ici ensuite
ça amène à lui 1 2 3 4 et là le seul 10
mars et 1 2 3 4 donc ce serait là ok je
pense le code est bon donc là je verrai
appuyé dans tous les trous du bas
puisque eux ils sont tous troué comme
vous pouvez voir c'est qu'il doit y
avoir un bon alignement pour pouvoir les
traversées donc là tu as fait rien c'est
sûr
là ça fait rien c'est sûr là par contre
de l'autre côté les 106 poucet çà fait
oui si c'est faux
la fin notre truc par contre c'est
bloqué c'est qu'il doit y avoir un
système d'aimants qu'il le tient à
l'intérieur ok ça m'a sorti une grosse
un gros truc comme ça mais version
géante j'ai l'impression
[Musique]
quand j'appuie sur lui je pouvais appuyé
aussi sur inquiéter là justement là sur
lui peut-être que oui d'accord ok donc
lui les tenues il est retenu par lui et
lui pour pousser sur lui faut d'abord
poussé sur celui qui a derrière la boîte
l'a juste de ce côté là et donc je fais
ça je fais ça j'enlève et ça me met là
ok cette routine clé ok est-ce que ça
m'a libéré autre chose je vais repousser
un peu partout dans tous les trous que
j'ai et je verrai à puis surtout ça ah
non non non non non non pourquoi je
refais ça vous avez compris parce qu'on
a ça va changer de position donc je
retombe tout au cas où la non la non la
non là non là non du coup on a quand
même les symboles de ce côté là qu'on
n'a pas tapé et si ça on a résolu on a
fait tout ce qu'on devait faire avec
celle ci que ça c'est l indice pour
comprendre je pense qu'on passe à celui
là parce que regarder ce que je vois moi
sur le côté je vois directement 1 1 2 3
4 exactement sur le même système
ici donc s'il ya encore un truc en
quatre temps c'est forcément pour ce
côté là une deux trois quatre de 3,4 ça
c'est une deux trois quatre
une deux trois de 3,4 alors là ce qui se
passe c'est que je cherchais le nombre
de traits j'ai cherché donc d'extrémité
surtout jours les deux extrêmes en
partant dans des extrêmes j'essaye puis
ça me parlait pas trop lui il ya un truc
qui me sautent plus haut village c'est
que sur celui ci doit vous voyez lâche
en fait ce grand trait je le retrouve
sur sus un sur ce symbole ce titre et il
est sur ce symbole ce trait là on le
retrouve là lui ils seraient fondues la
lui y serai là et lui il serait là donc
je crois qu'il faut fusionner les deux
pour faire le code comme ça en partant
de lui du coup la se serait inversée lui
ce serait le 1 et du coup lui ce serait
le 2g pas encore essayé pour le deuxième
je voulais qu'on le fasse en même temps
mais lui il faudrait que je cherche donc
quelque chose qu'à une grande barre ici
qui serait refermée puisque l'aca lui ça
irait là
en fait ce serait comme 1,8 qui serait
ouvert là mais que règne diagonale ici
un peu un peu comme ça mais là qui
serait refermée là et avec une diagonale
si d'actes manqués à 8
ici ça là c'est juste qu'en vrai il est
comme ça parce que c'est dérangeant je
pense pas pendant ce temps à veracruz à
goma par là
qui serait refermée en va si je regarde
le côté un coup sur deux on trouve du
premier groupe ok ça s'est résolu
maintenant comme d'hab on repasse tous
là j'ai un truc qui sort là j'ai un truc
qui sort là j'ai refermé m'ont fait
trois zigotos l'adopta là ok là il ya un
très grave et qui fait le flèche qui
vient là peut-être que dans l'alignement
ça me permet oui
et ensuite ça nous fait sortir ce petit
truc là où il ya des des points et des
traits d'une flèche de chaque côté à
l'arbre ci une flèche
ça nous fait points 1 créée et 2.2 dinos
parce que là on a eu très très pressé
haut en morse pointerait points points
c'est à dire quoi en morse
nous voici avec le code morse
internationale dont on a dit cela flèche
commencé comme ça donc pointé points
points ça fait pointer points points
c'est la lettre m
donc là on avait au on à elle ça sent
bon le haut elle y
c'est un r d si c'est ça ça veut dire
qu'il me remonte pas mal alors la teneur
n'a changé d'état donc ça vaut le coup
de repousser un peu partout 1 aux abois
voilà que ça continue au hockey
ol
i deux points c'est i 2 point sa série
[Musique]
et je vais continuer à pousser dans les
trucs à côté à la sas est sorti du coup
c'était juste soutenue par un aimant là
ok c'est sais comment c'est très
pointerait prend pointerait est-ce que
ça c'est pas prendre les points très bon
comme ça alors au lyon1 c'est pas un
truc aussi les poches il ya une flèche
une flèche là du coup ça voudrait dire
qu'on commence pas à lire de ce côté
donc très pro très point c'est bon ol
c'est là on cherche le à sept points
très bas ce serait peut-être plus à si
j'appelais au hockey bon ben c'est tout
un peu peut-être que c'est tout ol icea
ça suffirait dans le sein le rl100 les
dettes ou est-ce que lui j'aurais dû le
sortir plus tôt la gamme il ya écrit
fabien mais par moore 46 mm
je perturbais parce que j'ai mis le
hernie le dea en fait en même temps ça
ça ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
là ce trou là là ressemble énormément à
cette formule armes
c'était un acte et je me mets là un peu
pas du tout
mais manque le 1er et le des jeux vient
de tout essayé la avec ça je pense
vraiment qu'il faut que je trouve le rl
ligue des sur les six faces aux un
[ __ ] c'était pas fini en fait il
s'agit il suffisait de suivre les
flèches et là du coup on a quoi
pointerait points et pointerait point ça
se lit dans les deux sens donc c'est
pratique quand même c'est le r si je
n'ai pas de petit point très points wii
donc là il ne manque plus que des tas
fallait vraiment aller au bout donc très
profond là on a changé de position lui
est verrouillé donc je leur mette encore
partout
comment ça pue du savoir dans ce truc
mais n'a rien fait sur lui c'est quoi ça
et bien voilà des c'est quoi très points
donc la three points je les hais point
points et flèche vers le haut
très prend un point ah oui bah oui non
c'est sport le sens des lectures je
pense ok peut-être que mon mac l'est
peut-être qu'elle était dérouté parce
que ça il faut peut-être appuyer la
[Musique]
jemaye coeur je ne t'aime pas beaucoup
suffisamment pour faire ton castelain je
pense que c'est la fin
optimaux bien joué et bien joué deux
heures quand même bien joué et merci
d'avoir retourné le cerveau avec ce
nouveau casse tête mais que malgré tout
tu as passé un bon moment
créé pour une troisième boîte alors oui
ok ok attend ça c'est magnifique ça
c'est très joli mais ça je le garde le
goût de ses chaînes mais sa part quand
même dans les petits trophées de casse
tête
bravo bravo bravo alors bravo et fg
casse tête
bravo deux heures donc quatre fois plus
de temps qu'à première fois ci ne dis
pas de bêtises après si je peux faire
juste un axe d'amélioration
je trouvais que celle ci elle manquait
d'histoire c'est à dire que tu sait pas
vers où tu vas tu es pas habitué à faire
des castes et de cette casse la tête et
quand tu es habitué à faire des
cassettes ça te casse la tête mais pas
dans le sens plaisir parce que t'es
jamais sûr d'où tu vas alors que les
casse-têtes d'habitude au fur et à
mesure on s'est un petit peu on va ça
m'a manqué un petit peu d'histoire pas
d'histoire d'un sens une histoire
incroyable derrière le truc mais dans le
sens des espèces de là ok tu es sur la
bonne voie là t'es pas sur la bonne voie
si vous voulez construire les
casse-têtes dites vous bien que
si le but c'est de construire une boîte
que personne d'autre que vous pouvez
ouvrir c'est possible de le faire mais
ça n'a pas grand intérêt
là il suffit d'enlever tous les éléments
encore gravure et puis plus personne ne
sera jamais ouvrir la boîte mais il faut
quand même que y ait un petit peu
d'éléments que propose lui une dernière
accélération sur lesquels je mettrai les
boutons d'abonnement ainsi que les
autres vidéos à regarder
merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que vous passez un
bel été en compagnie de ce casse-tête 1
et et pourquoi pas je ne sais pas moi
lecture je prends un livre au hasard
parce qu'à un moment donné vous pouvez
très bien lire ce livre lentigny de la
manipulation
c'est excellent ici vous pouvez vous
abonner à cette chaîne c'est gratuit
n'oubliez pas de le faire activer la
cloche je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard ici vous trouverez deux autres
vidéos sur deux autres casse tête dont
le premier que m'avait fait fg m'écoeure
l'époque où il s'appelait mecar science
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]